all right chris i'll come to you first
on this one so sure you are essentially
the alan grant of this new trilogy of
films so now that you actually get the
opportunity to work opposite sam neil
was there anything about that that i
guess brought out something new in owen
that you didn't even realize was there
before
i would say everything about my
experience working with
sam
uh
the major takeaways i i would take from
the person of sam neil versus
owen learning something from dr alan
grant it was you know we shot this under
pretty tight coveted restrictions and we
were all essentially living together for
the better part of eight months
and so i took away from sam a lot of
really wonderful things and realized
that we had a lot in common
in our real lives we both have farms on
islands we raised the same type of pigs
the same type of sheep like there was
just all of these similarities literally
have the same type of suffolk sheep that
we rai it was like a very str
strange uh
mix of similarities uh and um i just
grown i just really really adore him as
a guy so
i'm not sure that nes i would i would
first think of all the things that i
learned from him and and
vibed with him as just a person as as
the man he's awesome i highly recommend
his movie rams if you haven't seen it i
feel like you would like it yes of
course yeah yes of course i remember him
telling me about it i haven't had an
opportunity to see it yet but i'm really
excited to see it very very good in it
all right so bryce one little bit that i
read in the production notes from you
and it was like one of my favorite
things that i read was that you kept a
list of ideas that the cast and crew
came up with during the first two films
and some of those ideas made it into
dominion so what inspired you to do that
and then what are some of those ideas
that we can actually see on screen in
the finished phone
well a google doc is my what is it chris
what what's this your love language it's
my love language a google doc is my
language
[Laughter]
so yeah so i mean it was just i like to
kind of keep notes when i'm doing a a
movie because you know for for
situations like this like with press so
that you remember certain things and
pretty early on chris would say stuff
that i would just be like oh my god if
there's
if there's a chance to do another one of
these movies that's like such a good
idea that's so fun and so um
so i just kind of like kept that running
document and um
colin asked me for it as he was writing
it with writing the script with emily
and and you know i'm just i'm really
happy something that was definitely on
that document was blue having a baby
that was that was something that was
very important the underground scene in
malta that was something that we talked
about really wanting to see yep um yeah
there was a few few few really fun
things in there i love that like one
when the time is right you should just
release that list i know but then again
i want this franchise
and you're going to be like oh my gosh i
remember you sending that to me i was
like these are all great wait
i was like chris i've been trying my
ideas
you're like i literally just told you
that i wrote down your ideas right right
you're really good though it's like
yeah i have about a four second window
of clarity around the moment that i'm in
and she does a really great job of
capturing of capturing so you do we're
just a good we're a good team i think
we're a good team in that way and in
many other ways as well yeah yeah but
it's fun very random question for you
bryce or a specific detail at least
because i am the biggest judy greer fan
please tell me does claire keep in touch
with her sister is she aware of what
she's going through yeah yeah yeah yeah
definitely definitely i think claire has
learned the value of family
after the first jurassic world
um yeah i mean i love judy greer we
played sisters in my first movie that i
did called the village and um and so to
get to play sisters again was just such
a blast just making me happy to know
that you guys think about each other in
like the head canon of we do we do
for you guys so much for your time today
and big congrats on the movie and the
trilogy thank you
you